die fraktionsspitzen im bundestag achten
geradezu eifersüchtig darauf dass keine
oder keine aus den eigenen reihen tanzt
sonst gibt es ärger heute konnte sich
die führungsriege entspannt zurücklehnen
jeder darf tun was er oder sie für
richtig hält man darf sich sogar mit
politischen gegnern verbünden zum wohle
der gesundheit fürst verpflichtende
impfen oder eben auch dagegen die
gewissensfrage der bundestag streitet
über impfpflicht jetzt in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
wächst hier im studio ist rea schröder
bundestagsabgeordnete der fdp und auch
mitglied im bundesvorstand ihrer partei
steffen ist bei uns 90 die grünen
ebenfalls mitglied im bundestag
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
bündnisgrünen fraktionen sie haben mit
sechs anderen abgeordneten den antrag
den weitestgehenden antrag vorgelegt
einer impfpflicht ab 18 jahren
zugeschaltet sind claudia möbius
autorin und coach sie sind in der
sendung als gegnerin einer corona
impfpflicht und das muss man auch dazu
sagen sie sind haben sich bisher nicht
impfen lassen und schließlich professor
timm ulrichs ist epidemiologe an der
akad hochschule hier in berlin frau
schröder war denn die
bundestagsdebatte heute für sie für die
für ihre entscheidungsfindung erhält
solche orientierungs debatten muss man
finde ich sagen das hat sich heute noch
einmal bestätigt sind wirklich ein fest
für die demokratie weil da sehr
unterschiedliche meinungen ausgetauscht
werden auch aus den verschiedenen
fraktionen wir haben gesehen es gibt ja
viele ansatzpunkte und ich habe heute
viel gelernt und viel mitgenommen aus
der debatte und ich hoffe so geht es
vielen bürgerinnen und bürgern auch die
zu hause in der familie im job diese
debatten auch gerade führen über die
impfpflicht und da sind wir glaube ich
heute ein gutes stück weitergekommen
zweieinhalb stunden hat es gedauert
herrscht dessen sie sind ja ich habe es
gesagt der vertreter eines antrags der
impfpflicht ab 18 hat denn die debatte
die heute stattgefunden hat ihre
zuversicht verstärkt dass es sich mit
ihrem antrag am ende durchsetzen werden
müssten der rahmen der debatte also wir
haben vorbereitende diskussionen in der
fraktion geführt und da habe ich schon
viele leute gehabt die sich positiv
zurückgemeldet haben die gesagt haben ja
ich würde das gerne unterstützen und
auch noch mal im laufe der debatte sind
auch viele auf mich zugekommen viele
leute suchen natürlich tatsächlich nach
orientierung sowie die debatte ja auch
soll und haben dann schon auch gemerkt
okay das ist glaube ich die liebe
richtungen das unterstütze einsammeln
gesagt ich habe noch mal fragen zu dem
im detail möchte ich gerne auch mal
nächste woche telefonieren also so weit
was ich gemerkt habe ist es hat einfach
ganz ähnlich köpfen ausgelöst so dass
wir tatsächlich vorankommen nettebad
also in die parlamentarische arbeit
jetzt auch beginnend vom mönius momentan
geht man ja davon aus dass eine mehrheit
im bundestag für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht stimmen wird das ist die
lage im moment kann sich noch ändern
aber im moment wird vermutet dass eine
allgemeine impfpflicht eine mehrheit im
bundestag hat und wenn die pflicht kommt
ist sie verpflichten dann ist sie
gesetzt dann gilt das gesetz für alle
auch für die das gesetz nicht gut finden
wie werden sie denn damit umgehen wenn
es zu einer allgemeinen impfpflicht käme
da muss natürlich dann erstmal sich was
in diesem gesetz wirklich kennt steht es
ist ja jetzt bereits um das heißt für
die
beschäftigten im gesundheits und
sozialwesen das ist eine impfpflicht
gibt aber wenn man genauer hin dass dies
ein schaut dann ist es überhaupt noch
keine impfpflicht sondern eigentlich nur
die vorschreibt dass arbeitgeber den
status an die gesundheitsämter melden
müssen und dass dann eben die
gesundheitsämter entscheiden ob es ein
betretungsverbot zum beispiel ausstellen
also man muss dann an sagte nording
gesetzestext lesen und sehen was es
verstehe gibt der hintergrund meine
frage war es ein bisschen auch ob sich
dann ihr impfstatus ändert
ja ist mir schon klar wenn man wie
gesagt da muss ich doch zunächst mal
sehen was das gesetz überhaupt
vorschreiben also sie sagten ja freuen
auch schon sehr wichtig einleiten heute
waren es in dieser parlamentarischen
debatte soll dass jeder tun darf was er
will und das was er für richtig hält
sagte sie und ich hoffe doch dass das
auch weiterhin so möglich ist dass wir
in diesem verein und demokratisches land
das tun können was wir für wichtig
halten immer natürlich berücksichtigen
ist dass wir andere nicht gefährden das
wissen wir ja jetzt auch inzwischen dass
auch die nicht geimpften auch nicht
keine größeren gefährder sind als die
geimpften zeit also da muss man auch
jetzt erst mal sehen wie sich das alles
entwickeln würden wir haben auch eine
neue sachlage durch die omikron variante
und weiß noch gar nicht ob die
impfstoffe die bislang vorhanden sind
überhaupt nicht helfen ihr schreiben
denn ob sie denn eigentlich gegen eine
mutante y im herbst helfen also das sind
jetzt noch aufwendig fragen wir
versuchen den trotzdem im lauf der
sendung noch etwas näher zu kommen herr
ulrich heute war ja diese orientierungs
debatte jetzt soll es ja sollen diese
anträge entweder ausgearbeitet oder noch
verfeinert werden es gibt daneben dazu
in den parlamentarischen verfahren
entwürfe man will sich zeit lassen für
die diskussion auch für die entscheidung
geht ihnen das alles etwas langsam voran
angesichts der aktuellen pandemie lage
naja es ist ja klar dass die impfpflicht
jetzt nicht mehr viel bringen würde da
nichts bringen wird zur bekämpfung der
omicron welle die wir zurzeit gerade
haben aber es ist eben sehr notwendig
dass wir uns gut aufstellen und auch
eine grundimmunisierung
reinbringen mit blick auf den herbst und
winter damit wir nicht wieder von vorne
anfangen müssen und ich möchte an dieser
stelle auch gleich mal frau -
widersprechen es ist eben nicht so dass
die gefährdungslage bei ungeimpften und
geimpften also was von denen aus geht
gleich ist sondern ganz im gegenteil
ungeimpfte gefährden mit ihrem ungeimpft
status und der dem risiko einer
erkrankung unser gesundheitswesen und
sie eben eben auch das virus sehr viel
leichter und schneller weiter als die
geimpften und gemusterten und das können
wir uns eben nicht mehr erlauben und
deswegen ist diese impfpflicht
eigentlich eben sehr notwendig ein
schlechtes instrument aber wenn andere
es nicht hilft müssen wir uns eben mit
dieser sache behelfen an dem was sie
gerade gesagt haben sich scheiden sich
ja im moment auch die geister das hat
man heute nachmittag auch in den
dreieinhalb stunden debatte im bundestag
gesehen wir wollen uns noch mal 56
sekunden aus diesen dreieinhalb stunden
anschauen das kommt jeweils ein
abgeordneter eine und zwei abgeordnete
zu wort die jeweils für eine bestimmte
position für einen der drei anträge
stehen und es beginnt der prominenteste
der brei nämlich der bundestags-
vizepräsident wolfgang kubicki wir
machen es uns viel zu ein treffen wir
erklären hauptsächlich corona leute und
rechtsradikale entschieden sich gegen
die impfung das ist mitnichten so wir
müssen den respektieren dass es durchaus
bedenkenswerte psychologische oder
religiöse gründe gibt eine impfung für
sich persönlich abzulehnen wir wären
hier wenn wir diese gründe im sinne des
allgemein schutzes als nicht zulässig
erachten würden insbesondere
dass wir mittlerweile wissen dass der
fremdschutz durch eine impfung kaum mehr
gegeben ist ich spreche heute als eine
vertreterin von den kolleginnen und
kollegen in diesem haus die vorschlagen
den sogenannten mittelweg zu gehen
obwohl ich mit dem begriff nicht ganz
ganz glücklich bin und dieser mittelweg
heißt wir machen eine verpflichtung zur
impfung ab 50 für die besonders
gefährdeten gruppen wir machen aber auch
eine verpflichtende impfberatung ab 18
lassen sie uns dem virus geschlossen die
stirn bieten stimmen sie für die
allgemeine impfpflicht vielen dank ja
also für die allgemeine impfpflicht die
letzte rednerin frau behrens von der spd
so schöner
wolfgang kubicki hat ja wahrscheinlich
aus meiner sicht heute auch applaus von
der falschen seite bekommen wir haben
das gerade gewährt man es nicht gesehen
kam vor allem aus der fdp fraktion wenn
sich seine position durch setzt das ist
es keine ängstlich kommt was dann was
denken sie wird dann passieren wenn es
also bei dem jetzigen zustand bleibt hat
man sich darüber auch schon gedanken
gemacht zum einen habe ich festgestellt
dass heute aus fast allen richtungen
applaus kam auch zu den
unterschiedlichen rednerinnen und
rednern und auch bei herrn kubicki vor
aus unserer fraktion geklatscht auch bei
den grünen wurde geklatscht auch von
linken parteien auch in der
unions-fraktion also das kann man glaube
ich nicht sagen und ich glaube danach
sollten wir auch den inhalt der
vorschläge nicht beurteilen wer dafür
klatscht denn es geht hier um
grundrechtseingriffe die müssen gut
begründet sein und die frage ist ja
brauchen wir überhaupt noch eine
impfpflicht also herr ulrich hat es ja
eben auch angesprochen omikron betrifft
das nicht sondern wir reden darüber was
passiert im herbst und ich bin juristin
ich weiß nicht was im herbst passiert
und ich glaube da gibt es auch unter den
biologinnen und biologen sehr
unterschiedliche meinungen zu der frage
und keiner weiß es denn das wissen wir
nach zwei jahren das unvorhersehbar und
deswegen ist aus meiner sicht ganz
wichtig dass wir dann maßnahmen
ergreifen wenn sie notwendig sind eine
impfpflicht jetzt
kann im herbst schon wieder eine ganz
andere lage vorfinden deswegen gibt es
jetzt gerade keine notwendigkeit und
eine nicht notwendige maßnahme die darf
man auch nicht einführen wenn die
impfpflicht nicht kommt wenn sie sich
doch nicht durchsetzen mit ihrem antrag
ich mache mir große sorgen dass wir dann
tatsächlich im herbst wieder die gleiche
situation rauschen wie in den letzten
beiden jahren dass wir dann wieder
massiv das öffentliche leben
einschränken müssen dass wir wieder in
situationen reinlaufen wie wir sie dann
auch jetzt erleben dass wir kinder und
jugendliche massiv einschränken müssen
tatsächlich um den über das überlaufen
der intensivstation zu verhindern das
ist die große sorge die ich habe und ich
kann ganz klar sagen ich bin nicht der
mediziner und psychologe aber als jurist
und als jemand der lange in verwaltung
bearbeitet kann ich sagen man kann nicht
im september ernennt pflicht beschließen
dies im oktober und november hilft
sondern wir müssen dafür sorgen dass ist
ja auch die lehre aus all dem was wir
jetzt erlebt haben wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass er geordnete abläufe haben
dass wir eine systematische impfkampagne
aufbauen eine also dass die
impfmöglichkeiten da sind dass
informationen angeboten wird all das
muss systematisch aufgebaut werden das
geht nicht im hauruck prinzip und
deswegen müssen wir das alles
vorbereiten es ist ja schön wenn wir
dann feststellen dass löst sich alles in
wohlgefallen auf aber dafür spricht
momentan nicht sehr viel und es spricht
er mehr dafür dass auch nikon nicht die
letzte variante gewesen sein wird - ich
nehme an dass sie im herbst auch nicht
für die impfpflicht sein werden nehmen
sie denn da zugespitzt gefragt belegt in
kauf dass wir eben in den nächsten
corona winter schlittern dass es an
wechsel zwischen lockdown und
lockerungen gibt je nach incidents zahl
wie soll es dann weitergehen aus ihrer
sicht mit der pandemie wir wissen ja
noch nicht ob omikron tatsächlich der
schlussakkord ist
also erstmal müssen wir noch sehen ist
vor einigen jahren überhaupt noch keine
impfung und wir hatten niedrigeren
instanzen als jetzt jetzt sind über 70
prozent geimpft und die inzidenz geht in
die höhe in anderen ländern in denen pro
t höher ist haben wir noch bei gehöre
incidents bei uns sondern wenn man nach
spanien oder portugal schaut also
vielleicht das können wir doch mal
anerkennen dass impfen eben nicht der
weg oder nicht mehr alleinige weg aus
dieser pandemie sein kann das finde ich
aber ganz wesentlich dass man das nicht
einfach unter den tisch fallen lässt und
wenn man biologen und neurologe auch
studiert gibt viele meinungen die eben
oder einige die sagen es ist anzunehmen
dass sich diese mutationen weiter
abschwächen und nikon also die
abschwächung von delta nach objekten war
doch schon sehr deutlich es ist doch
ziemlich unwahrscheinlich dass jetzt
plötzlich wieder
andere varianten kommen die einfach
wieder sehr viel gefährlicher sind warum
treibt man denn jetzt aber diese angst
weiter so in die höhe schade dass man
mal sagt es scheint sich diese
herdenimmunität gebildet zu haben es hat
ja ursprünglich money heißt 70%
impfquote wenn wir haben dann sind wir
durch ja es wird ja die ganze zeit nur
wenn diese werte erhöht jetzt 80 oder 90
prozent also sie denn niemand dass das
nicht der alleinige ausweg sein kann
dass das man kann ja immer schlauer
werden gegenüber früher aber na ja und
ich soll kann ich ganz sicher die frage
gleich weitergeben schießen wir da mit
kanonen auf spatzen
nein auf gar keinen fall und auch hier
muss ich frau - vehement widersprechen
also man kann nicht einfach diese
korrelationen hier in den raum stellen
und dann versuchen da in der causa die
täterin zu sehen als wir noch keinen
impfstoff hatten haben wir auch ganz
anders reagiert mit entsprechenden
kontakt beschränkungen um die neu
infizierten zahlen zu drücken deswegen
kann man diese situationen überhaupt
nicht vergleichen mit jetzt wo wir eine
variante haben die sehr viel
ansteckungswege ist und die jetzt gerade
in der tat auch schon vollständig
dienste und gemusterte anstecken kann
aber das entscheidende ist ja bei der
impfung wogegen soll sie schützen sie
soll natürlich auch bestenfalls vor
einer ansteckung schützen aber vor allen
dingen vor der erkrankung und das tut
diese impfung auch wenn sie noch nicht
spezifisch auf die omikron variante
zugeschnitten ist
sehr effektiv und das ist das was wir
haben was wir brauchen und zusammen mit
einem kontakt auch mit der nikon
variante aber auch mit den impfungen
alleine kommen wir in eine phase wo wir
eine grundimmunisierung
einbringen können und das bedeutet dass
wir auf diese art und weise aus der
pandemie rauskommen und nur auf diese
art und weise wenn wir das nicht tun
dann haben wir eben sehr wohl ein risiko
dass wir im herbst und winter wieder in
eine solche welle reihen laufen und
frau schröder hat ja gesagt also es gibt
hier dinge die man nicht vorhersehen
kann doch man kann sehr wohl voraussagen
dass wir wieder eine welle haben werden
und wieder rücksicht nehmen müssen auf
alle die ungeimpft sind die nämlich dann
ein risiko haben ins krankenhaus zu
kommen und wir müssen uns davor schützen
dass wir in eine überlastung dar
einlaufen weil sie ja gleich darauf
reagieren sehr gerne also das ist
natürlich sie sind da der experte ich
habe das angedeutet wir sehen ja jetzt
eine situation wo wir mit der omicron
variante eben eine veränderung haben wir
sehen jetzt dass die hospitalisierung
zahlen nach unten gehen wenngleich die
inzidenz zahlen nach oben gehen das
heißt wir müssen uns auch klar machen
wenn wir über eine impfpflicht sprechen
was ist das ziel davon ich finde es kann
nicht darum gehen zu sagen da muss jetzt
mal dampf abgelassen werden von all
denjenigen die sich an die regeln
gehalten haben ich kann das zwar
emotional verstehen aber das ist keine
legitimation für den grundrechtseingriff
der eine impfpflicht darstellt und auf
der anderen seite und worum geht es
eigentlich es geht darum das
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
dafür zu sorgen dass keine operation
nicht und durchgeführt werden können und
das ist das worüber wir sprechen das
heißt wir müssen schon gucken in welcher
weise stellt sich die situation im
herbst da sollte es so sein wie jetzt
mit omikron dann würde ich sagen in
einer solchen situation dürfte eine
impfpflicht nicht greifen weil eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystem
momentan nicht bevorsteht und deswegen
müssen wir auf andere maßnahmen
zurückgreifen die weniger grundrechts
einschränken sind wolfgang kubicki sieht
seine position als sozusagen der
gegenspieler von ihnen gesagt hier
mehrheiten dürfen da nicht über
minderheiten bestimmt es gibt
tatsächlich auch triftige gründe sich
nicht impfen zu lassen an die
psychologische oder auch religiöse
außerdem sei ja der fremdschutz
eigentlich gar nicht mehr vorhanden im
impfstoff was gegen sie da auf diese
positionen geht es ja darum führen wir
jetzt die impfpflicht einführen dass sie
nicht ein wir haben ja auch die
unterschiedlichen positionen jetzt
gerade von frau - und an und riss gehört
es geht natürlich genau darum also was
jetzt ja alle gesagt haben wir müssen
die intensivstationen schützen davor
dass sie über laufen was heißt dass
jemand der aus ganz anderen gründen also
sei es ein herzinfarkt verkehrsunfall
eine intensivstation braucht dass er
auch wirklich dann darauf zugreifen kann
zum glück sind der bislang daran vorbei
gekommen so auch deutlich sagen also bis
dann wird jeder versorgt er so massive
dafür hat aber wir sind auch schon
ziemlich hart an grenzen gekommen darum
geht es zum einen zum anderen ist es das
ja richtig gesagt worden eben dass wir
bei den ungeimpften eine wesentlich
höhere viruslast haben und sie
wesentlich mehr zur verbreitung des
virus beitragen können und wir deswegen
die ganze ausbreitung nicht in griff
kriegen das ist ja der hintergrund und
wenn wir jetzt sagen wir kommen da immer
noch nicht weiter wir gehen immer wieder
in diese schleife dann haben wir eine
situation wo der anteil von ungeimpften
und wenn es 20 prozent sind das die
natürlich am ende darüber entscheiden
wie die gesellschaft sich überhaupt
entwickeln kann wir sind total
eingesperrt in den
entwicklungsperspektiven ich bin in
meinem wahlkreis ganz oft im austausch
mit mit einzelhändlern die können
überhaupt nicht klar die haben gar
keinen optimismus mehr und darum muss es
ja gehen dass es stabile perspektiven
gibt da wird uns extrem viel wegbrechen
wenn nochmal anzeichen corona männer
gehen
es geht unter anderem bei dieser
diskussion auch darum wie eigentlich
sollte die impfpflicht kommen für die
sie ja eintreten sie tatsächlich
kontrolliert wird und auch am ende
funktioniert
eine möglichkeit wäre wie in österreich
ein impf register aufzubauen dass wir
gar nicht haben das würde noch dauern
deswegen wird es jetzt auch abgelehnt
wir haben das nicht und deswegen sollten
das ohne ins register machen was er
sonst alternativ machen komme ich gleich
noch drauf
warum fordern sie nicht dass es
wenigstens mittel und langfristig
angeführt wird also ich persönlich würde
das nicht ausschließen es ist nur so wir
müssen als zielperspektive diesen auch
an der skeptischen haltung ihrer
fraktion zu dieser frage ich glaube man
muss über die details eines solchen
registers immer sprechen wenn man so
etwas errichtet also das ist ja auch so
es ist mitnichten so dass das
datenschutzrecht das nicht zulassen
würde sondern es kommt immer darauf an
die art und weise wie man die daten
erhebt sammelt wer darauf zugreifen kann
und so weiter in abwägung zu dem zweck
und deswegen gibt es natürlich die
möglichkeiten auch sowas
datenschutzkonform zu machen ist auch
immer ein risiko da sind natürlich
sensible daten und das muss man abwägen
aber steht uns jetzt in der zeit die wir
haben und es geht jetzt zielperspektive
den herbst nicht mich rechtzeitig zur
verfügung da haben wir einfach andere
voraussetzungen als österreich die früh
angefangen haben deswegen müssen wir auf
andere varianten zurückgreifen die fdp
sie auch etwas oder nicht etwas sehr
datenschutzsensibel
kein ins register heißt man wird
sozusagen nach der bekannten manier in
der korona pandemie in den letzten zwei
jahren sozusagen den schwarzen peter
weiter reichen was die kontrolle an geht
also auch die frage ob ein
verpflichtender ins nachweis vorliegt
für arbeitgeber für gastronomen für
u-bahn kontrolleure und
konzertveranstalter ist das
schafft das vertrauen die politik dass
man quasi beschließt möglicherweise eine
impfpflicht die kontrolliert werden muss
die sanktioniert werden muss aber die
kontrolle die üben andere aus die dafür
eigentlich gar nicht zuständig sind das
ist aus meiner sicht nicht der beste weg
ich glaube da gibt es natürlich noch
große debatten darüber aber vor allem
ein zentrales im frigges da das den ich
ganz entschieden ab also dass da
sensible gesundheitsdaten irgendwo
zentral gespeichert werden das möchte
ich nicht obwohl ich eine große
befürworterin der impfung bin und jeden
auch dazu aufrufe das zu tun möchte ich
nicht dass meine daten gespeichert sind
das sind eher so die überwachungs
fantasien aus der union jeder einzelne
redner jeder einzelne rednerin hat es
heute angebracht aber wir haben ja auch
andere möglichkeiten erwachsene
volljährige personen an zu schreiben zum
beispiel über die krankenkassen wäre die
möglichkeit oder über die kommunen das
ist natürlich auch was das muss man
klären ist ja der aufwand aber wir
hätten auch diese möglichkeit menschen
an zu schreiben das ist ja auch ein weg
der vorgeschlagen wird ihnen ein angebot
zu machen ein beratungsgespräch
anzugeben anzubieten das ist glaube ich
auch etwas was wir was ein milderes
mittel ist als ein eingriff in die
körperliche unversehrtheit und dann ganz
kurz noch hätten wir ja auch darüber die
gelegenheit diese diesen vorzug zu
ermöglichen die frage wie man an zu
schreiben städte wie berlin scheitern ja
schon wahlbriefe korrekt zuzustellen als
berlin aber auch wirklich ein schlechtes
beispiel alle anderen das überall sonst
funktionieren na ja bei allen außer
berlin - sieh dir als coach tätig sind
sind haben damit viel kontakt mit
menschen ist es da ein problem für sie
dass sie nicht geimpft sind in diesen in
ihrer beruflichen ihrem beruflichen
umfeld
also ich muss jetzt erst mal sagen dass
ich durchaus dieses virus ernst nehme
und dass sich auch die möglichkeit an
der infektion ernst nehmen von daher von
anfang an sehr achtsam unserer sorgsam
damit umgegangen bin und
selbstverständlich an alle regeln halte
und abstandsregelung und viele online
mache und momentan kann die seminare
anbieten weil ich auch seminare unter
zwei bedingungen mir anbieten höher als
bei mir keinen ausschluss von personen
gruppen gibt es in ethisch würde ich nie
tun also ich halte nicht das sehr an
diese ganzen vorgaben könig gleich noch
was dazu sagen zu dem thema
angeschrieben werden wir haben hier in
meiner heimatstadt nürnberg sind wir vor
zwei wochen alle bürger und bürgerinnen
angeschrieben und aufgeklärt praktisch
noch wenn man solle sich noch impfen
lassen und es lag ein beiblatt dabei
wichtige informationen zur corona
impfung mit ganz einfach gehalten
piktogrammen und mit mehr oder minder
drei fortsetzen und ich muss ihnen ganz
ehrlich sagen ich finde das wirklich
eine von bislang eine diffamierung man
wird immer so hingestellt als weil man
schlecht informiert ich habe mich von
anfang an sehr intensiv mit diesen neuen
impfstoffen geschäft es sind ja keine
konventionellen stoffe wie wir sie schon
kennen von
30 mio sondern es ist eine völlig neue
technologie ist geht um diese
technologie und es werden permanent auch
schäden die entstehen wirklich schwere
impfstellen einfach totgeschwiegen also
es gibt ja neben dem von kubicki heute
angesprochenen
religiösen gründen und psychologischen
gründen erwähnt hat gibt es auch noch
einfach medizinische gründe es gibt hier
an den offenen brief von über 400
ärztinnen und ärzten die den an den
bundestag geschickt haben an alle
gesundheitsminister der des bundes der
länder und in dem sie wirklich warnen
auch vor diesen impfschäden die es jetzt
auch zu hause gibt 100 mal mehr als bei
klassischen herkömmlichen verfahren des
niedergangs von möglichen langen
unterbrechungen eben auch noch nicht
kennen es ist eine neue technologie gut
sie haben sollen es 400 ärzten
gesprochen dass geschrieben haben also
heute sind fakten bekannt geworden die
sammelt ihr das paul-ehrlich-institut es
sind 162 millionen impfungen in
deutschland bisher verabreicht worden
gegen die korona pandemie von den
schäden die bestätigt und anerkannt
worden gibt es insgesamt 18 das ist eine
quote von 0,00 0 01 prozent es gibt noch
andere anträge auf impfschaden
anerkennung die ihm noch ihnen sozusagen
bei den entsprechenden behörden liegen
42 tote sind anhören venenthrombose
verstorbenen seit anfang 2020
möglicherweise
oder später im jahr 2020 durch die
impfungen verursacht
kann man da wirklich behaupten dass die
impfschäden ein gravierendes argument
gegen das impfen sind promis
wichtiges wort erwähnen sie sagen die
anerkannten impfschäden also sehr viele
mehrere sich ungefähr 200 entschuldigung
sind etwa 260
anträge auf im schatten die noch nicht
anerkannt sind vielleicht noch anerkannt
werden aber das sind eben auch nicht
sehr viele na ja die frage ist eben was
mit den überhaupt gemeldet was mit den
weitergeleiteten grill eine
dokumentation die ist ganz neu in
österreich
beträgt wollen momentan auf servustv
einsehbar rechts ist ja mal völlig soll
ard gesendet zu werden berichten
menschen aus fleisch und blut von ihren
ganzen problemen kardiologischen
neurologische schwerste schäden
dermatologische schäden und zwar nicht
nur kurzfristig sondern jetzt wirklich
schon länger damit zu kämpfen haben und
die momentan von sich selbst sagen sie
belasten das gesundheitssystem weil sie
nämlich von einem zum anderen arzt gehen
und geschickt werden und keiner kann ich
nicht helfen kann diese schäden heilen
also das können wir doch nicht einfach
ausblenden und das ist meine große
kritik auch an diesem ganzen
aufklärungen und informationen es wird
aus meiner sicht nicht sachgerecht
aufgeklärt ist also würde ich eher
einseitig in die nächste frage es gibt
ja durchaus menschen vielleicht so in
der größenordnung 10 bis 20 prozent in
deutschland die so denken wie frau news
dass er sofort aufklärung schon gefallen
ich habe jetzt die fakten oder die daten
des paul-ehrlich-instituts zitiert frau
hoeneß hat ihre positionen dargestellt
haben wir noch eine aufklärungs defizit
was impfen in deutschland angeht
ja also sie haben schon recht also
erstmal die zahlen sind ja sehr
eindrücklich und sprechen eigentlich für
sich und es gibt noch weitere gute
argumente
warum diese neue technologie eben eine
ist die sich auch in zukunft durchsetzen
wird und noch in ganz anderen bereichen
beispielsweise in der onkologie ein game
changer sein würde in der behandlung von
fällen und auch in der prophylaxe aber
es ist so und das wir natürlich an allen
ecken und enden versuchen zu informieren
und aufzuklären
es ist natürlich immer schwieriger
menschen zu erreichen die dann da er
eine verhärtete positionen einnehmen und
sich dann auch vor einer argumentation
er verschließen außerdem finde ich es
war bisher immer eher ein defizit auch
darin die gegenargumente die gebracht
werden von den kronleuchtern und den
impfgegnern auch wirkt wirkungsweise
oder wirkungsvoll zu entkräften und wenn
ich jetzt gerade ich habe jetzt gerade
zuge etwas vor - gesagt hat also das
sind alles dinge die so gefühlt werden
aber eben nicht auf
nachprüfbaren fakten beruhen und es sind
eben die fakten die es hier gerade
genannt worden sind über das
paul-ehrlich-institut was man nachlesen
kann und zwar nicht nur in deutschland
sondern in vielen ländern wurden diese
neuen impfstoffe alle gut überprüft und
nach gehalten man könnte sogar sagen
viel besser als manch anderer
konventioneller impfstoff der auch bei
seiner einführung dann ja ähnlich
begleitet worden ist und vom - wenn sie
das ablehnen mit dem mr an impfstoff
dann würde ich ihnen empfehlen doch
gehen bald zugelassen werden den tod
impfstoff zu nehmen und sich damit
impfen zu lassen das ist zwar nicht ganz
so wirkungsvoll wie die klinischen
studien zeigen aber auch sehr gut hier
einen beitrag zu leisten dass das virus
eingedämmt wird dass sie auch nicht ein
risiko haben schwer zu erkranken und auf
eine station im krankenhaus zu müssen
wenn wir das ganz kurz noch würden sie
denn das machen werde dass eine
alternative für sie
also zum einen würde ich nicht noch mal
gut beraten lassen ich möchte mal ganz
was sagen ist politisch schon wieder
gesagt pro monat leugner und gegner ich
bin weder das eine noch das andere
das war schon wichtig dass wir hier auch
sachlich bleiben und dieses narrativ
herr dieser
rechtsradikalen verschwörungstheoretiker
spur oder etc hier nicht weiter beginnen
damit auch sehr dankbar dafür guter
vertreten zu den anderen impfstoffen ist
zu sagen man ich werde nicht beraten
lassen wie ich das auch bis dahin
gemacht habe ja von ärztinnen und ärzten
denen ich vertrauen und ich werde mich
genau oft da informieren was sind denn
für wirkstoffe drin und dann werde ich
für mich entscheiden ob ich meinen
körper damit eben belasten möchte oder
nicht was ich durchaus sagen kann ist
dass ich sehr stark präventiv arbeitet
das ist was was wir in der ganzen
öffentlichen debatte total fehlt also
wir leben sehr gesund ich bewege mich
ernähre mich sehr sehr gut ich dachte
wirklich auf meine gesundheit mit
heimischen 10 mit vitamin d mit zehn was
man im winter eben auch so zu führen
kann und ich halte es für sehr viel
verantwortungsvoller als dass ich mir
den sogenannten verhandlungs
ausgedrückten tipps in den oberarm geben
lassen und dann mit meinem suv an die
nächste schritten bude fahren und nicht
entsprechend
dem thema auf ich weiß was der
unterschied zwischen ernährung corona
epidemie es gibt eine pandemie es gibt
die meisten biologen und epidemiologen
sagen ja diese 75 prozent im vorjahr ich
nicht aus um die epidemie in den griff
zu kriegen das heißt sie müssen von den
übrigen 25 prozent noch eine ganze reihe
überzeugen und offenbar haben das jetzt
auch gerade gehört kommt diese
überzeugungsarbeit nicht an denn man
hätte sich schon längst impfen lassen
können welches defizit haben da die
politikerinnen und politiker eigentlich
ja sozusagen sich aufgeheizt oder
funktion sind sie verantwortlich für
richtig ich glaube dass wir natürlich
schon auch defizite an bestimmten
stellen haben wo wir zu schnell wechsel
vollzogen haben ich will ein beispiel
aus meiner eigenen heimatstadt hamburg
sagen hatten wir gut funktionierendes
zentrales im zentrum das war dann auch
angenommen und das haben dann auch leute
mitgekriegt die sich nicht so aktiv
informieren die wussten dann irgendwann
was das gibt dann wurde es ein herz
geschlossen dann dieses jetzt wäre
vielleicht gut wusste und dann gab es
diese infrastruktur nicht mehr und das
ist sicher ein fehler dass wir diese
stabilen nachvollziehbaren strukturen
dann aufgeben also das ist das was wir
brauchen wird auch immer viel gesagt
aufsuchen empfang gebote auch wichtig
aber ich glaube viele leute hier ist
einfach wenn die information leicht
verfügbar ist und sich nicht ständig
ändert wo man sich ein kämpfen lassen
kann das ein ganz wichtiger punkt und
ich würde auch sagen klar es gibt ganz
viele informationen zum thema zum teil
auch viel leitende informationen aber es
gibt natürlich viele informationen was
ich vermisse ist eine information die
auch noch mal ganz zielgerichtet dann
auch an die gruppe heran geht wo auch
defizite sind also zum beispiel habe ich
gehört dass in
geburtsvorbereitungskursen viele junge
frauen sagen ich lasse mich nicht impfen
weil ich möchte ja noch kinder kriegen
muss man sagen okay das ist ein thema
darüber können wir konkret reden die
sorge ist im ergebnis unbegründet das
kind ist gefährdet wenn mutter während
der schwangerschaft die korona
erkrankung kriegt aber darüber gezielt
zu sprechen und gezielt diese gruppe
anzusprechen da kriege ich ihnen jeder u
bahn für die frage
geschlechtskrankheiten zielgerichtete
information als jetzt irgendwie die
allgemeinen im kampagnen in berliner u
bahn
das ist bundesweit und da gibt es viel
bessere erfahrungen spricht man die
unterschiedlichen gruppen an und da sind
wir bei der impfkampagne eigentlich ein
bisschen langweilig da sind in
frankreich gezielt bessere kampagne
nicht abdanken gut das hat man gesehen
im vergleich der plakate der jetzt schon
vorgestellt worden sind und die in
frankreich an allen ecken und enden
hängen frau schröder es gebe ja die
möglichkeit ein paar tage
fraktionskollege von ihnen ende und man
hat das ja jetzt vorgeschlagen so eine
art kompromiss also in fliegt ja aber
erst ab 50 vorher ein aufklärendes
gespräch
verpflichtendes könnten sich das
vorstellen dass man sich darauf einigt
hätte das auch vorteile
ich würde ich begrüße das sehr dass wir
das auch diskutieren dass damit auch ein
anderer vorschlag auf dem tisch liegt
weil wir also aus verschiedenen gründen
ich glaube man muss zum einen sehen es
gibt noch vieles was wir vor einer
impfpflicht tun müssen die impfkampagne
wurde angesprochen aber es geht ja auch
darum nicht nur dafür zu werben
aufzuklären sondern auch dass man
wirklich über eine impfmöglichkeit
darüber stolpert wir haben wir müssen
glaube ich auch mehr selbstbewusst dafür
werben dass dieser impfstoff dass das
ein luxus ist den wir haben das wir dass
menschen anbieten können in deutschland
in der vergangenheit hätten sich
menschen darüber gefreut wenn sie eine
ein solches heim mittel zur verfügung
gestellt bekommen hätten in deutschland
begegnet das auf skepsis also wir haben
da glaube ich noch viel nachzuholen auch
in der wissenschaftskommunikation in der
werbung für das impfen und ich glaube so
ein verpflichtender termin er kann ganz
bestimmte gruppen eben noch erreichen
manche erreicht man nicht mehr das sehen
wir auch aber es gibt auch gerade viele
junge erwachsene die einfach bisher noch
nicht die zeit dafür hatten sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen und bei denen so ein
sanfter druck gut ist aber es ist eben
leichter auch in das grundrecht auf
allgemeine handlungsfreiheit
darauf zuzugreifen als auf die
körperliche unversehrtheit und deswegen
ist das aus meiner sicht ein vorzuziehen
da weg wir müssen alles getan haben
bevor wir menschen verpflichten sich
impfen zu lassen und wir müssen auch und
das ist so ein stück weit meine kritik
auch an der allgemeinen impfpflicht im
gegensatz zu einer impfpflicht ab 50
jahren wir müssen das mildeste mittel
wählen und diejenigen die auf den
intensivstationen sind das sind nicht
die 25-jährigen sondern das ist die
generation 50 die fdp bildet ja ein oder
präsentiert ein sehr vielfältiges
meinungsbild in dieser frage bundestag
wolfgang kubicki und älteren mann stehen
für unterschiedliche angriff frau stark
zimmermann dritte dem antrag von till
steffen auf allgemeine impfpflicht bei
bekommen dass der fraktion so gut denn
dieses thema wird uns noch lange
beherrschen und möglicherweise auch noch
zu vielen kontroversen führen wenn sich
die fdp so im bundestag in dieser frage
so aufspaltet
ich sehe das überhaupt nicht als ein
problem sondern ich sehe diese offene
debatten kultur in unserer fraktion als
einen ganz großen gewinn wir sind in
ganz vielen themen einer meinung und weg
kommen auch aus sehr unterschiedlich aus
der ähnlichen richtung wenn wir schauen
welche einschränkungen muss freiheit in
kauf nehmen um andere freiheit zu
gewährleisten das heißt wir sind da von
dem werte set sehr ähnlich aber wir
treffen eben am ende unterschiedliche
entscheidung und aus meiner sicht
bereichert das debatte die debatte
einige der anträge die jetzt im
bundestag vorliegen kommen aus unserer
fraktion ich glaube das steht dafür dass
wir da sehr aktiv sind und uns gut
einbringen
unruhig sie haben vorhin wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere erwähnt dass diese
impfpflicht wenn sie denn jetzt käme im
frühjahr diese mikrowelle sowieso nicht
mehr verhindern könne also für den
herbst eigentlich die wichtige
prophylaxe prävention wäre aber ist
diese strategie vielleicht nicht auch
ein bisschen unklug wenn ich sage also
das jetzt für die omikron welt zu spät
und der herbst ist ja eigentlich für
viele auch noch weit sie vielleicht die
gefahr oder gar nicht befürchten dass
möglicherweise aus dieser impfpflicht
diese ja für dringend notwendig halten
so ein bisschen die dynamik rauskommt
dass man da so ein bisschen die lange
bank schiebt und sagte impfpflicht haben
wir noch zeit weil ob für omicron ist eh
alles zu spät also ist es von der stadt
von der strategischen vom strategischen
diskussions ansatz nicht richtig
naja es ist ja so dass es für die
omikron wellen zu spät ist also auch
wenn wir jetzt anfangen würden das
verpflichtend einzuführen dann würden
wir keinen nennenswerten npd
biologischen effekt wir haben auf den
pick also auf die höhe und auch auf die
breite dieser kurve aber wenn wir uns
die vorangegangenen saison angucken also
herbst und winter 20 21 und 21 22
dann haben wir ja immer mit diesen
großen wellen zu kämpfen gehabt und es
ist eben sehr wahrscheinlich dass wir in
diesem herbst und winter wieder eine
bekommen werden das heißt sich
entsprechend vorzubereiten das wäre
jetzt das mittel der wahl und ich gebe
ihnen völlig recht wenn wir wieder in
den frühling gehen und in den sommer
dann wenn die fallzahlen niedrig sein
werden dann ist auch dieser druck nicht
mehr da aber die diskussion sollte eben
jetzt geführt werden auch vor der macht
vor dem erfahrungshintergrund dieser
vorangegangenen wellen und jetzt haben
wir tatsächlich die chance uns
vorzubereiten sonst sind wir immer
diesen bällen hinterher gelaufen und
waren niemals vor der lage sondern haben
immer wieder lockt downs beschließen
müssen weil nichts anderes hatten und
das impfen das kam erst schleppend
gedanken das heißt also wir waren
niemals vor einer welle
und jetzt können wir tatsächlich diese
planung so machen und mit der
impfpflicht als zwar kein schönes
instrument aber ein notwendiges uns hier
so aufstellen dass wir es eben zu einem
ende bringen können und dann langsam in
die endemische phase überreden
bei ihnen noch erwähnen sie haben ja
eine krebserkrankung überstanden gehirn
möglicherweise auch zu einer gefährdeten
gruppe ich habe jetzt von ihnen genießen
sie hätten vor allen dingen eben angst
vor den langzeitfolgen einer impfung die
man ja noch gar nicht kennen kann wie es
heißt das ja wir haben gerade ja schon
darüber gesprochen also die eben die
impfschäden halten sich da in grenzen
haben sie denn keine angst vor den
langzeitfolgen einer profit erkrankung
der so genannte long coffee dass manche
menschen für der rest des lebens eine
große belastung bedeutet ist das für sie
ist das sie nicht haben sie davor keine
angst
also ich hab einfach eine persönliche
risiko abwägung getroffen ich sage
nochmal ich verharmlose das wir uns
nicht und ich weiß auch dass es losgeht
gibt das ist überhaupt keine frage nur
es gibt eben auch andere probleme
anderer geschädigter knipser komme ich
habe auch diverse erreger haben habe ich
ihn mir eines epstein-barr-virus was
magistris in fieber auslöst borrelien
und es gibt auch wissenschaften die
davon waren und sagen dass durch diesen
bauplan für dieses protein was wir ja
mit diesen stoffen angerechnet bekommen
dass da die nun abwehr so geschlecht
wird dass diese schlafend hier erreger
möglicherweise
explodieren in uns und ich sage ihnen
ganz ehrlich ich habe lange für meine
persönliche gesundheit gekämpft und ich
habe viel darum gerungen und ich habe
meine ganze lebensweise umgestellt und
ich sehe nicht ein dass ich andere
probleme mir dadurch schaffe dass ich
mir diesen noch immer logischerweise
nicht langer zeit erprobten stoff in
meinem rad einführen lassen und ich habe
auch keine lust long position bekommen
gar keine frage aber es ist eine
risikoabwägung und sie haben mich freuen
größte unterbrochen und haben isabel
dass ernährung mit kroner zu tun haben
ich persönlich glaube dass eine gesunde
lebensweise ein herforder kinderschutz
ist ihr part natürlich mit achtsamkeit
momentan dass man jetzt nicht in großen
gruppe unterwegs ist etc das ist der
persönliche schutz für den ich mich
jetzt gerade entschieden habe ich weiß
auch nicht ob es richtig ist ich kann
nur sagen nach allen informationen die
ich gesammelt habe bin ich für den
moment zu dieser entscheidung der frau
ich habe
87 bin und adipös und diabetes hat
schaut vielleicht und ich hatte von
unterbrochen weil das thema jetzt nicht
ernährung ist sondern impfpflicht
genau und das gehört ja auch zu wie ist
das eigentlich wenn wir das jetzt hören
es gibt ja viele menschen die
möglicherweise angst um ihre gesundheit
haben wenn sie sich impfen das ist für
manche ja auch der grund
nicht impfen zu gehen wie geht man mit
diesen so genannten
variablen gruppen um die jetzt also
nicht sich nicht durch profit eigentlich
bedroht fühlen sondern durch die impfung
weil sie angst haben dass ihre
gesundheit damit beeinträchtigt wird
ja in dem man eben noch mal gut darüber
informiert also es ist man kann da
wirklich sehr beruhigen eine solche
impfung also die ja nur den bauplan von
einem virus anti gehen in den körper
bringt die kann nicht dazu beitragen
dass das immunsystem an anderer stelle
schwächer wird sondern ganz im gegenteil
hier gibt es ein training und dieser
bauplan wird eine weile abgelesen von
den körpereigenen zellen dann werden die
zellen dann dieses dieses antigen von
dem virus exprimieren und das
immunsystem kann daran lernen und es
kann mehr hat mehrere räder gleichzeitig
abwehren das macht es jeden tag und hier
ist es so dass tatsächlich dann mit
dieser weiteren aufstellung eben auch
ein eine einen schutz gelegt wird er
auch lang anhaltend ist endlich über den
anderen impfungen und natürlich auch mit
der konfrontation mit entsprechenden
erregern also von daher frau - kann ich
sie sehr beruhigen da ist gar kein
anhalt dass da irgendwelche
schlummernden erreger die gibt es ja in
der tat irgendwelche viren dann wieder
reaktiviert werden können nur weil das
immunsystem jetzt in diese richtung
gelenkt wird sondern ganz im gegenteil
das ist ein training und das immunsystem
kann sich hier breit aufstellen es gibt
kollegen von ihnen in den letzten 180
grad anders kann man vielleicht auch
noch mal so gut es gibt unterschiedliche
positionen ja man sehr leicht
gut wenn man ganz leicht widerlegen also
das ist das sind eben nicht haltbare
aussagen man kann die studien
entsprechend dazu heranführen und das
auch im ökologisch begründen das
immunsystem ist ja nicht so schwach oder
schlecht aufgestellt dass es sich dann
genau so verhalten würde sondern ganz im
gegenteil
und mit dem impfen gibt man dem
immunsystem etwas an die hand was dazu
beiträgt es eben gut aufgestellt zu
haben wenn ein erreger kommt dass er
sofort abgewehrt werden kann
möglicherweise nicht die infektion
verhindert werden kann aber gerade bei
menschen die gefährdet sind durch
grunderkrankungen
daneben das risiko stark abgesenkt
werden dass bei einer darf verminderten
abwehr das immunsystem dann
möglicherweise überfordert ist oder dass
gerade jetzt wieder bei punkt 19 dann
das dann ganze organe betroffen sein
könnten wie die gut auch im
fortgeschrittenen zustand der pandemie
der krone pandemie ist es ganz foto ens
gedankenaustausch gibt vielleicht hätten
wir uns viel ärger erspart und jetzt
kommen wir zum fluch der bösen tat von
politikern wenn man nicht im letzten
jahren politiker vieler oder vielleicht
auch aller parteien gesagt haben also
sozusagen heilige schwüre abgegeben
haben es kommt auf keinen fall eine
impfpflicht und jetzt halten diese
impfpflicht viele für unentbehrlich
dieses kommunikations desaster hat der
diskussion und auch der glaubwürdigkeit
der politik schwer geschadet also in den
tri allen hat annalena baerbock auf die
ausdrückliche frage gesagt sie schließt
das nicht aus hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen weil sie hat nicht diesen
vollständigen ausschluss gemacht und ich
finde das auch die richtige position
weil wir natürlich nicht wussten wo
kommen wir weiterhin in dieser pandemie
und jetzt sind wir in der tat in einer
situation ich fände es noch falscher
wenn die politik sagen würde wir haben
irgendwo was anderes gesagt wir dürfen
auf keinen fall was dazulernen und darum
geht es jetzt die situation jetzt zu
lesen und zu sagen was müssen wir tun
damit wir freiheit wieder gewinnen und
die antwort von meiner gruppe ist die
allgemeine impfpflicht andere schlagen
andere wege vor aber tatsächlich sich
dem zu stellen ich denke das ist der
wert dieser auseinandersetzung was lernt
man daraus für die zukunft dass man
nicht etwas ausschließt was man dann mit
der gleichen logik ein halbes jahr
später zurück nimmt und damit die
bevölkerung verunsichert
ich glaube das ist in der pandemie
ohnehin anzuraten aber ich gehöre
steffen da recht also es wäre sehr dumm
wenn man schlauer geworden ist nicht
etwas zu tun was man jetzt weiß was man
noch nicht wusste also wenn man das
wirklich ja noch nicht wissen können
oder zumindest ahnen können dass es
vielleicht zurücknehmen muss man hätte
ja auch etwas vorsichtiger formulieren
können das hätte man sicherlich machen
können ich glaube wir lernen daraus dass
es sehr sehr wichtig ist zu
argumentieren dass man es sehr sehr
wichtig ist klare worte zu finden
deswegen auch eine klare abwägung zu
treffen und ich glaube die debatte heute
im bundes die hat dazu sehr positiv
beigetragen und ich hoffe sehr dass wir
den ton weiter beibehalten
und da sich auch viele menschen daran
beteiligen wenn sie auch in zukunft in
der phoenix runde machen klare worte
damit auch klage wird um was es geht ein
wichtiges thema das im moment alles
beherrscht das war's drei nämlich bei
ria schröder bei till steffen bei
claudia möbius und bei timo unterrichts
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]